Hello this is Peter Cooper.
Welcome to today's NCBI Minute webinar on
the SRA RunSelector.
The answers and questions that are asked during
the webinar will be available in a document
that will be linked to the webinars page.
There's also a materials directory on the
ftp site that has Ashley's slides.
And this compressed URL will take you there.
So I'd like to introduce Ashley Hintz who
will talk to you about the SRA run selector.
All right, thank you very much.
We will go ahead and get started.
What are we going to talk about today?
We will talk about the structure of the SRA
database, what the run selector is, how to
use the filters, getting access to the data,
and we will go through a couple of examples
of the SRA toolkit command.
This is a diagram of a standard SRA submission
set up.
At the top we have two studies that were submitted,
those are directly linked to the BioProject
and they will also have an SRP accession number
in SRA.
Each one of these studies has multiple samples
linked to it and these are directly linked
to the registered BioSample.
They will also have a unique SRS accession.
You can see there's one sample in the middle,
it is called the control, it is party to both
studies.
That is perfectly acceptable.
Underneath the study and the samples we have
two more categories, Experiment and Run.
This information is directly stored in SRA.
Experiment accessions with the SRX number,
have all of the metadata provided by the researcher
contained within it.
Underneath that we have the SRR number which
is the run accession.
This is where the actual data files for the
sequence data are stored.
You can see in some of the samples, one experiment
linked to multiple runs and some samples have
multiple experiments and multiple runs.
There are different ways to set up SRA to
fit your research project.
What is run selector?
It is a table view of you of SRA data available
from your search terms.
We'll go through a demonstration of this after
I lay out the basics.
This allows for more precise filtering of
the SRA metadata, it collates the common columns
of data between the projects, with a couple
of exceptions, there has to be a 10% similarity
between the data columns and fields with large
number of characters will not be included
because it makes the table harder to read.
There is a limit of 20,000 run accessions
that can be viewed.
Finally after you have filtered down the data
to where you want, you can export the data
accessions and the metadata as a spreadsheet.
Let's jump into the demo.
We will start from the main NCBI page.
I have SRA database selected.
This is where you can enter in any search
term.
Be sure the search term is relatively specific
so you get below that 20,000 run accession
limit.
I am interested in ancient DNA.
Click Enter.
This will take me to all of the SRA experiment
accessions that we have for the search terms.
On the left hand side you can see there is
an Access area.
I want to point out that you can use the run
selector on dbGaP data.
In this case we are only going to look at
public data.
I'm gonna go ahead and click that.
You can see there is a box at the top that
asks me if I want to send this data to the
run selector.
Which I do.
So I'll go ahead and click that.
After it caches the data you will see a view
like this.
You'll notice on the left-hand side there
is a box labeled, Facets.
This is all of the data column headers that
you can use to filter the table.
You will notice that the Center is automatically
selected.
This is the default.
If you don't care which center the data came
from, you can click on the red minus button
and it will make it go away.
Now I can filter the data the way I am interested.
We will start with organism.
As you can see we have lots of different data,
for multiple organisms.
I am interested in human data.
I'm gonna type in that genus.
There are two different species for the genus
Homo.
We have Homo sapiens, of course, and also
Homo heidelgergensis.
I am interested in Homo sapiens so we'll click
on that one, and you notice that the table
automatically updates.
I had over 2000 runs and now I have 486.
The next category I am interested in looking
at is the Assay type.
I'll click on that.
It also identifies how many runs are labeled
as each of these categories.
I am interested in whole genome sequencing,
so we'll click on that category, and again
my table will update.
I'll make a couple more selections here.
I will select a particular library.
We have hybrid selection, unspecified, and
random.
I am specifically interested in random.
Finally I want a specific spot length.
Let's type in 60; I want them at least 60.
Once I type that in, you can see there are
only three categories that fit that criterion.
Select all three of those.
Each time I do this it will update.
Now I have 131 runs that fit the criteria
that I am interested in.
You will notice not all the accessions in
the table start with that SRR letters.
These begin with an ERR.
That means it is coming from our European
database, our counterparts in Europe.
Our database mirrors with European and Japanese
databases for next generation sequencing data,
so when you search our database you are not
only looking at SRA data, you are also looking
at data from those two organizations.
You're getting three databases.
I can sort each one of these columns.
If I click on it, it's going to sort by the
letters and numbers.
So forwards, then backwards.
Then I can see all those SRR accessions.
In this case there are not very many because
ancient DNA is more prevalent in Europe, for
doing research.
That's why you see a lot more ERR accessions.
You will notice the first four columns are
blue hyperlinks.
I can click on one of these and it will send
me to the information for that particular
run, study, bioproject or sample.
This one looks interesting, just because it
says ancient DNA of a metagenome.
Right click and open that in a new tab.
This takes me to all of the run data and I
can see how many spots it has, the size, the
GC content and at the bottom I can see the
title for this project, it is specifically
from a tooth from a victim of the Black Death.
That's kind of cool.
Let's just scroll out here so I can show you
a couple more things.
You can see for some of these categories there
are runs that are blank, the researchers chose
not to enter information for that particular
category.
Keep that in mind while you're filtering the
data sets and looking through them, the data
are provided to us from research communities
so not all of the columns will be filled in.
In this case we are doing pretty good; there
are some missing collection dates.
Let's say all of the data looks good, I want
to export it.
Click the green plus button and it will select
everything in that spreadsheet.
Maybe I am not interested in that black death
victim, so I can unselect that particular
run.
And you can see under our selected column,
I have 130 runs selected, and I will download
that information.
Okay, it's under Downloads; let's see if I
can find it.
Now I want to open that in Excel.
Now here I have to make sure I select All
files because when you select to download
the run table information it will download
as a tab-delimited text file.
Make sure you select All files.
Choose that it is delimited.
And I have to choose that it is tab-delmimited.
Again Next.
Then click finish.
I'll make the columns a bit wider.
Now you can see here is that same information
that was in the run selector, it is now in
my spreadsheet and I can save it, make notes,
and come back to it later.
The other option for downloading the information
is just to download a list of the run accessions.
This is the most important accession number
that you will get from this table, because
as previously stated the actual data files
are resting under the run accession numbers.
We will download our accession list.
I will open this in notepad plus plus.
Okay, here are all my run accessions.
All 130.
All right, let's jump back into our slideshow
here.
Now you have all this metadata information
and all of these run accessions, how do you
get access to the actual data files.
You will use the SRA toolkit.
This is a commandline application that works
on all current 64-bit systems; Windows, Mac
and we have two versions of Linux.
You can download the data in multiple data
formats, the most common being fastq.
For any aligned data you can also download
bam files, and we also have SFF files, among
others.
You can limit the amount of data that you
download.
Maybe you are only intersted in chromosome
1; maybe you're only interested in the back
half of chromosome 16.
You can enter in those sections when downloading
the data so you don't have to obtain the entire
large data file.
Another thing the SRA Tooliket does is BLAST.
You can blast data from SRA including barcodes
or aligned slices.
And that's just the beginning.
Here are a couple examples of commands you
can use in the SRA toolkit that you can use
to access data.
For a standard fastq download you would use
fastq-dump and the SRR number.
This function includes options for splitting
files if it's paired data, and also only downloading
a section of the file.
If you want to download a bam file, make sure
you have to filter by aligned data and you
need to have samtools installed on your computer
because they work together.
You're going to use sam-dump and the SRR number
to get your sam file, then take it directly
into samtools to convert it into your bam
file.
Then finally an example BLAST command.
So it's blastn_vdb.
And in this case there are three different
run accessions we're querying against.
The other thing to point out is this nt.test
file; this is the actual sequence you are
searching for.
So here is the nucleotide sequence to see
if it's in any of these run accessions.
And then dot out will give you the results.
Here are the links for all the information
that we talked about today, including some
additional information about the SRA database.
And with that I'm happy to take questions
Just to remind you while we are open like
this, if you have any questions about any
of the resources you heard about today, or
any NCBI resources in general, you can write
to our info address, info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov,
that's the same domain name as our web page.
If you have questions about the webinars program
or webinars in general, please write to the
webinars address, webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
I don't see any questions that we can answer
right now.
Thank you very much for attending the webinar
today.
That is all for today.
We will see you next week on the 30th for
a webinar about the NCBI Hackathons.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you for coming.
Thanks Ashley.